after destroying shinnob try Borg turned  his attention to the Special Forces  general blade and the others fought  valiantly but their human weaknesses led  to their inevitable defeat now with  access to the SF computer network try  Borg used it to interface with the Lin  Kuei storage drives from which he  respond he saved the brainwave data of  dozens of his Lin Kuei brothers and  sisters to the SF servers the SF  laboratories provided the materials  necessary for tri board to create  cybernetic bodies for each one soon the  downloads were complete the cyber Lin  Kuei had been reformed but because  sub-zero had forever selling the clans  name try board decided to begin anew he  would henceforth be known as the leader  of the deadliest clan in all the realms  the takuan  you